there was a gal who just went
went viral
thanks to our friends at libs of tick
tock
she she posted a tick tock she's a
teacher
and she says you know in the class my
kids are you know they're supposed to
say the pledge of allegiance at least in
some schools you're still supposed to do
that
but we don't have an american flag in
our class we've got a very different
flag
during third period we have
announcements and they do the pledge of
allegiance i always tell my class
stand if you feel like it don't stand if
you feel like it say the words if you
want don't have to say the words so my
class decided to stand but not say the
words totally fine except for the fact
that my room does not have a flag it
used to be there but i took it down
during covid
because it made me uncomfortable
and um
i packed it away and i don't know where
and i haven't found it yet
but my kid today goes hey um it's kind
of weird that we just stand and then you
know we say it to nothing and i'm like
oh well you know i gotta find it like
i'm working on it i got you
in the meantime i tell this kid
we do have a flag in the class that you
can
pledge your allegiance to and he like
looks around he goes
oh that one
and it's the pride progress flag which
is different it's not just the rainbow
flag it's the rainbow flag with a bunch
of other colors and it makes it like a
racial thing and it's a flag to the
allegedly universal
radical leftist ideology okay
there was a
i think he calls himself a conservative
columnist but he's much more either
centrist or really center-left conor
friedersdorf i believe is his name and
he
he came out and posted on twitter about
this and he said you know this is cancel
culture stop
shaming this random teacher this is we
shouldn't we conservatives shouldn't
be engaging in cancel culture
and i think that is a that is not right
i think that's a very
i hate to be harsh i think that's a very
shallow take as as you know in my book
speechless
number one national bestseller thanks to
all of you who ordered the book and read
it appreciate it
i
think that the way we talk about cancer
culture is very silly because all
cultures cancel all cultures have
standards and taboos
if a culture pledges allegiance to one
flag which is a symbol of a country it's
a symbol of a way of life it's a symbol
of certain values and traditions
then it is necessarily excluding
other
values traditions nations ways of life
if you pledge allegiance to one flag you
are excluding other flags
got to push pause just for one second so
that i can ease your mind
when you are
in your home let's say you're in the
back of your home when you are at the
office okay let's say maybe you're on
vacation labor day is coming up
and someone goes knock knock knock
it's nice to be able to see and speak to
whoever is at your door
if someone's going around the back of
your house
it's nice to be able to see what's going
on if someone's in your house
really nice to know what's going on you
can do all of that with ring alarm
you can protect your home anytime from
anywhere with ring alarm and it's super
inexpensive not just to get
not just to get the actual product i i
love it so much i'm getting it now for a
relative of mine i've given it to
friends of mine as a housewarming gift i
really like it's just pure peace of mind
for me especially when i'm on the road
but you can get it right now
even to protect it you know those old
expensive home security systems you
don't need that anymore okay ring you
can keep it up every month super low
price go to ring.com knowles get a
special offer on a ring alarm security
kit today build a system that's right
for your home have it up and running in
minutesring.com knowles ring.com
knowles
this teacher has made a decision she is
not going to put the american flag in
her classroom she doesn't like america
she doesn't think her students should
have any particular allegiance to
america she thinks that
that students should have allegiance to
radical leftism
which ought to replace america
it's it's a flag that's not it's not a
national flag the pride progress flag
it's an imperial flag it's saying that
these values this this idea
is true everywhere on earth
it's just as true and just as good as
just as valid in timbuktu as it is here
whereas that would not be the case for
the american flag a national flag
so she says that's what you're going to
pledge your allegiance to hee-hee giggle
giggle giggle
this is a woman who is paid presumably
by our tax dollars
she is a citizen of our country she has
obligations to our country she's she's
educating
a generation of children and she's doing
a very poor job of it she's educating
them in the wrong way that is not
satisfactory
not acceptable for future americans and
she should be fired
she should be canceled it's good it's
really good to cancel some people and
some things
as as bill buckley said if a if a nazi
were teaching sociology
at yale
when he was fired no one would call it
cancel culture okay
and we we understand that that's true
for things on the far right or
politically unclassifiable things but we
we don't accept that that's true for
things on the left and the left does
understand that which is why the left
has taken over the whole culture and has
really taken over our whole politics
that teacher should be fired that video
should go viral she should at the very
least be reprimanded that flag should be
ripped down and
desecrated the pride progress one and
she should
be forced to put the american flag up
there and then those students should be
forced to stand up and pledge allegiance
to their country
and if they don't like their country
they can either get out when they're
little kids so they'll probably need
their parents to go get out or if they
don't like their country and a lot of
people are a little upset with our
country right now then they need to make
it better but they have an obligation to
it
because it's their country
and and we have an obligation to our
families and to our communities to our
states
and to our country
and we have a responsibility to make our
country a little bit better
[Music]
[Music]
you